the narrative
is actually moving in real time we have
seen it in the last 24 or 48 hours where
suddenly
oh masks maybe they're not great maybe
uh we should open up things maybe we've
been really the ones saying this the
whole time this is cnn's leanna wen she
is one of their medical correspondents
she's the former president of planned
parenthood that's just an interesting
tidbit of information there uh and we've
got a
bit of a compilation of her on how the
science has changed
do you agree with the move
i do there was a and is a time and place
for pandemic restrictions but when they
were put in it was always with the
understanding that they would be removed
as soon as we can and in this case
circumstances have changed case counts
are declining also the science has
changed we know that vaccines protect
very well against omicron which is the
dominant variant everyone five and older
have widespread access to vaccines and
we also know about one-way masking the
idea that even if other people around
you are not wearing masks if you wear a
high-quality mask that also protects you
the wearer too and so in this case i'm
not saying i don't think anyone really
is saying that no one should ever wear
masks but rather that the responsibility
should shift from a government mandate
imposed from the state or the local
district of the school rather it should
shift to an individual responsibility by
the family who can still decide that
their child can wear a mask if needed
man that is just extraordinary i'm not
for gulags for my political opponents
but i i don't know what you do with
someone like her i mean that is
profoundly evil she has been pushing
mandates she has been pushing masks the
idea that everyone has to wear them now
she's saying you could wear two and they
shouldn't have to do it also the science
has changed no the science hasn't
changed and this idea that suddenly oh
now we know that the the vaccines work
on omicron two weeks ago they were
telling us it didn't work on omicron and
that's why everybody was getting coveted
over christmas in the new and new years
and everything else so now here's the
compilation of her saying completely the
opposite over the past two years
one other thing that we're seeing now
and i think this is a response to the
rise of delta is more willingness among
governmental authorities and others to
mandate the vaccine we saw that
yesterday the va said it's going to
require the vaccine for its employees we
saw the mayor of new york the governor
of california do you anticipate seeing
more in this vein more requirements
yes and it cannot come soon enough you
can remain unvaccinated if you so choose
but if you want to be in public and
potentially could be infecting others
with a dangerous and sometimes fatal
disease that's highly transmissible
then
there's an obligation of society i mean
i think you could have an opt-out the
way that france for example or italy and
other countries are doing saying that if
you want to be in bars restaurants movie
theaters etc either be vaccinated or
have proof of a recent negative test i
hope that we moved in that direction as
a country here because at the end of the
day i don't really understand why people
have the choice to be infecting
our vulnerable children or
immunocompromised people or even others
who have taken the responsible choice to
get a vaccination sure and i just first
want to clarify that i was opposed to
the csc
back in may when they lifted the indoor
mass requirement i thought that the
honor code was never going to work that
when vaccinated and unvaccinated people
are mixing unless there is proof of
vaccination everybody should still be
wearing masks and so i actually support
what the cdc is now doing which is going
back to this indoor mask requirement
because frankly we know that we can't
trust the unvaccinated that they have
been walking around without masks and in
fact that's what led to the surge that
we're seeing vaccine is the ticket back
to pre-pandemic life and the window to
do that is really narrowing i mean you
were mentioning chris about how all
these states are reopening they're
reopening at a hundred percent and we
have a very narrow window to tie
reopening policy to vaccination status
because otherwise if everything is
reopened then what's the carrot going to
be how are we going to incentivize
people to actually get the vaccine so
that's why i think the cdc and the bond
administration needs to come out a lot
bolder and say
if you're vaccinated you can do all
these things here all these freedoms
that you have because otherwise people
are going to go out and enjoy these
freedoms anyway
oh
if you need a moment to grab a bucket
and puke
maybe i could pause for just a second
because she's disgusting absolutely
disgusting there is so much it's not
just that it's dishonesty in there and
and this deep like desire to control
people but the way she says it i don't
understand why people have choice that's
what she said i don't understand why
people have the choice
i understand because in america you got
choice lady okay that's number one then
at the end what's the carrot if you open
up everything she's telling you we are
the government and she's she's a
government agent she's not a she's not a
journalist even though they put her on
the clown network cnn what is the carrot
if we let them do things mean meaning if
we just give them freedom which they
think they give us right which they
don't give us but they think they give
it to us and actually the more that we
let them
believe that the more that they'll keep
taking uh then then why why would they
do what we want if they've already got
the carrot
right because rabbits like carrots and
rabbits usually uh when they're
domesticated live in little cages and
that's what they would love for us so
this woman is an extraordinary liar what
she's realizing right now and what cnn
and this is what i taught what i'm
saying about the the narrative shift
they're all realizing that everyone
really hates the democrats right now and
you really should you really should i
mean that these people have destroyed
lives
they have they have broken our education
system they have caused depression and
drug use to skyrocket they have
destroyed our cities
the the damage that has been done
because of democrat policies all of
these people cheered on
by the media who are just democrats on
television
the damage that has been done will be
two generations easily the i knew it you
go back to the videos that i was doing
two weeks after covet i did the two-week
thing we all did the two-week thing and
then i started saying you know the old
world ain't coming back it's pretty
obvious it's pretty obvious and those
people have killed the old world and
they are trying to condition us to a new
world that is going to be much worse
okay much worse so now here's another
democrat this is representative hakeem
jeffries from new york and you're not
going to believe who's who who is he
crediting you're not going to believe it
because the states are going to start
opening up now kind of doing what
florida's been doing all along doing
what texas has kind of been doing and
tennessee's been doing and all those
scary red states have been doing who's
he crediting now that the blue states
are going to open up because they want
to win in the midterms
yeah he's crediting brandon take a look
and the omicron variant is in retreat
and that's not by accident
that's because under president biden's
leadership
a public health infrastructure was put
into place
beginning with the american rescue plan
without a single republican vote
to ensure
that we can do everything possible to
crush the virus
and that is what has been happening
i'm gonna have to start drinking in the
middle of the day
i really am i don't like day drinking i
know a lot of people like to day drink
even on the weekends never been a fan
okay i like drinking when it's dark out
but the extraordinary level of lies it's
thanks to to joe biden that omicron is
in retreat no it isn't it's because the
vaccines did not work the way that joe
biden and lyanna wen and fauci and
walensky and all of you collection of
elitist liars pushed on us it didn't
work that way and guess what happened
over christmas and into the new year
everyone basically got omicron or got
some variant of covid including yours
truly and i did have leg pains for three
days and then i took the monoclonal
treatment which was easily accessible
here in florida which now the federal
government has stopped i took ivermectin
which isn't just a horse paste and yes i
was okay in three days and some people
were a little more sick david was a
little more sick
my brother got it at the exact same same
time as me he wasn't really sick i
wasn't really sick i'm not vaccinated he
is everyone made choices for themselves
it has nothing absolutely nothing to do
with the policies of these people